the latest Tik Tok Trend this gal she
goes me when I got news in 2011 that we
got him yes yeah great 2023 reading
osama's letter to America knowing he was
right he was right actually before you
even read the letter I did want to
mention in reading the letter I could
only think of this tweet that I saw the
other day under settler colonialism any
kind of resistance is branded as
terrorist because the only acceptable
violence is Violence by the occupier so
please keep that in mind when reading
the letter they seem to be selectively
reading the letter I'm I'm very excited
for the the libs who are promoting the
letter to America by Osama Bin Laden I
can't wait for these Libs all of whom
voted for Hillary in 2016 to get to the
part of the letter where Osama justifies
the 9/11 attacks in part on America's
failure to punish Bill Clinton for the
Monica Lewinsky Affair I can't wait for
them to read the part of the letter the
many parts of the letter that contradict
all of their behavior